like you can make like a like a mop
water is that what it's called like a
mop water what is it soap a floor wash a
floor wash God why don't that take so
long what's up guys this is Caroline and
these are my 10 essential my first
essential is lip gloss it's funny
because I don't have any lip gloss on
right now and I don't have any makeup on
for size mascara so bear with me there
we go always clear I don't like sparkles
I don't like pinks I mean a nude is kind
of cool like depending on you know how
serious you want to get but I don't
really think that I'm much of a color
lip type of person in general like it
just gets so intense
I always keep lipgloss in my purse in my
pocket in my car there's definitely lip
gloss in like the cup holder in my car
it's probably really hot right now
probably melting and I should probably
go Katie after this but it's there for
sure my next essential is Mountain
Valley spring water and this one it says
or cooling water because I ran out of
this bill and I despise sparkling water
who likes spicy water that's too dumb
props to you if you do you got a strong
throat me not so much it's spicy water
that doesn't sound refreshing it sounds
painful
your poor throats god bless you actually
Mac Miller put me on my Mountain Valley
spring I walked to his house and he had
like the dispenser and I was like why is
this the best water ever had in my life
and he put me on the kind of water and
we actually ended up getting a dispenser
in the house but on the go you need the
bottle ones and they're glass so you
can't reuse them and I think that that
really important for the environment
it's super important for me I just hang
here to have water on deck but even more
so as a mom
my baby is bougie so all her um well
she's bougie as far as like this goes
she drinks my own body spring water from
jump my next essential let me put on my
glasses for this because getting in my
director bag my next essential as -
Williams the director is my camera this
is one of my favorite essentials this is
my Canon EOS our we shot my album cover
on this camera we shot all four music
videos that are out will except for
toxic that was shot off my MacBook but
the last three music videos we're all
shot on this bad boy front cover back
cover basically the parody of my last
album is this game and every music video
we continue to shoot after the ones that
are out are also shot on this camera
which I picked up with Best Buy curbside
pickup during the quarantine so that we
could have really really high quality
videos and also has the flip view for
people this is a different kind of water
my next essential is a la de Florida
Florida water which is used for
cleansing and protection of the space of
the self of the item it's kind of like a
holy water I mean it is technically a
holy water
but you can clean your altar with this
bring a little bit on yourself before
you go somewhere when the coronavirus
started and mopped all the floors with
it people hide it a lot around me
growing up and then I smelled it once it
was like what is this
this smells crazy it smells like a dude
it smells like like slightly different
from like rubbing alcohol but like a
little bit all Florida water shout-out
Florida
next is the mini-fridge it
this mini-fridge is for my face products
nothing's in here right now because
that's heavy but this is where all my
serums go all the stuff that needs to
remain in a cold cool place I'm a skin
care in it so I thought that this would
be cool just feels refreshing and it
feels also like calming like if I have
redness and my skin is like irritated
and like a bunch of cold products going
on it I feel like is really soothing my
next essential tremor oh please if you
know me first of all on the Tori's you
don't have to know me to normal Tori's
I'm pretty loud about it but that means
that my entire life revolves around like
the utmost level of comfort I can create
and also like the quality of the comfort
this is about the most high quality
candle you could probably get actually
dump oh because I'm sure there's some
like super fancy rich people candle that
I don't even know about that you
probably got to be in like the
Illuminati to like access the candle but
these are the ones okay there's like 80
freakin dollars but they make your whole
house smell like a spore a good store
not a bad store not like a corner store
not like the liquor store you don't want
your house to smell they're either one
of those but if your house smell like a
really nice like clothing store there we
go
top-tier chefs kiss there's certain
candle smells I don't like in certain
places like I would never put like a
sweet dessert smelling candle in my
bathroom that's awful
you got to use one of those like ocean
breeze in the bathroom I also would
never quit citrus necessarily I think
in my bedroom I think that's a little
too like bright in invigorating for like
the bedroom also I don't like heavy dude
smells like it just smells like a big
just like grown man has been chilling in
my room that's cool for the car get your
little black ice you know I'm saying but
not for the beverage I mean I come home
and I love my I let my handy like I just
I just want to be immersed in the smell
good at all times like it really bothers
me deeply when there's like in off smell
in the house especially having a baby
you just know if you have it if you have
a baby that isn't potty-trained like I
feel like you get phantom poop smell
we're like even if the baby hasn't just
pooped like you almost everything every
so often you're like do y'all smell that
is there poop somewhere like you know so
pretty scary but it exists it's a thing
my next essential is my new favorite
game it's called the end this game is so
right it's a bunch of cards that have
all these questions on them that help
you communicate like openly and freely
and deeply with either people you're
dating your family your co-workers
there's like a wee bit in relationship
for hella long obviously and now we're
playing this version so in the dating
one it says stuff like woman's the last
time you held someone what do you think
is my biggest conflict right now will
you look at me what do you see and like
both you guys have to answer the
question but it's really cool cuz I feel
like it's a prompter for conversations
that some people are maybe nervous to
have and I think that the family one is
really helpful as well especially when
you live in a house with your siblings
it was actually my assistants idea she
found it sending to me he was like I
think you would love this cuz I just I
like to talk with people I mean
everybody should it's kind of how we're
getting through all this together so I
went kind of crazy and Mike bought
almost every version of the game
and ever since I picked it up I can't
put it down my necks ascension is so
important as quarantine is black seed
oil okay it's disgusting
a matter-of-fact smelling it because the
top is off is actually making me wanna
die
this is what you take like a tablespoon
of every single day and it's super good
for your immune system and I really have
to hold the top of it because it's takes
oh it's all my fingers it like burns a
little bit but it's so good for you and
I highly suggest everyone take some
black seed oil every day it's kind of
one of those things that you always
learn growing up if your family was into
naturopathic response to body stuff like
instead of going and grabbing a Tylenol
your mom would say you know do this or
do this or take some of this just like
fish oil oregano oil low oil they all
disgusting but they're super helpful the
more disgusting probably the better for
you my next essential is my diaper bag
yeah buddy this diaper bag is the Holy
Grail I think the worst thing you could
do is realizing you left and took the
baby somewhere and left the diaper bag
or you left and have the diaper bag but
the diaper bag is in packed correctly
then it feels like the whole road is
crumbling and what are you gonna do so
inside my diaper bag I have empty
bottles I have measured out formula I
have food I have change of clothes I
have diapers of course wipes basically
everything my child could possibly want
and need while we're outside in the
world thinking looks really cool it's a
cool brand and has a lot of pockets my
next essential everybody who knows me
knows I go through about 50 million of
these a year it's a bow feed first of
all I'm a mom so my phone can never die
like ever it's just not allowed to die
what if I need to call someone what if I
need help what if I'm gone and she's
with her babysitter or she's with her
dad or she's with my sister like they
need to be able to get in contact with
me at all times my phone
not allowed to die as a mom on top of
that I'm a working mom my phone can't
die when I'm in the middle of the booth
reading my lyrics off my phone screen my
phone can't die when I'm like reading
emails and responding to emails you know
it just can't die so these are super
helpful we just keep them charged up and
usually someone holds it for me because
I will probably set it down and if you
like flip my house upside down and shook
it and all the contents fell out they
would probably be like and I'm ashamed
to say it but maybe possibly 30 movies
in the cut somewhere they're not all
this big though this one's pretty
intense you do gotta remember to charge
in low fees but you know who does that
my assistant charted the movies it's if
I don't have an assistant my phone would
always be dead
my assistant is the best she might be my
last essential but that truly I would
not be functioning as a normal human
being feted Hatter and that's sad to say
that's sad but I also do a lot all right
Thank You GQ thank you for pulling up to
my crib and checking out our tuna my
favorite most essential essentials and
see you on the flipside